[Music]
this morning thousands of people have
taken to the streets of myanmar to
protest at the army's seizure of power
earlier this week president biden and
the united nations have called for the
country's military leaders to relinquish
power
and to release activists and officials
in increasing signs of resistance to the
coup people from all walks of life are
mounting a campaign of civil resistance
roxanna saberi reports from our london
bureau
thousands of protesters spilled into the
streets of myanmar's largest city on
saturday
chanting down with the military
dictatorship and holding up three-finger
salutes
signs that critics of last monday's coup
are growing bolder
as the demonstration swelled authorities
restricted internet access and broadened
a ban on social media
this follows a week of other peaceful
displays of defiance
with residents banging on pots and pans
night
after night and some doctors and
teachers
refusing to work this woman says
you don't want anyone who steals power
and then forms their own government
since seizing power last monday
myanmar's military has declared it would
stay in power for at least a year
the commander-in-chief alleges
november's parliamentary elections were
fraudulent
a claim dismissed by the country's
election commission
the governing party of aung san tsuchi
won in a landslide
now she's under house arrest as she had
been for 15 years
struggling against previous military
rule before troubled democratic
transition began in 2011.
tsuchi had turned into a symbol of
peaceful resistance
but critics say after she became the
nation's top civilian leader in 2015
she failed to address the army's deadly
crackdown on myanmar's minority rohingya
muslims
entire villages were destroyed and
hundreds of thousands
fled to neighboring bangladesh the u.n
called it
ethnic cleansing still widely adored at
home
tsuxi now faces a possible prison term
over the charge of illegally importing
walkie-talkies as restrictions on the
internet grow
so too do concerns that the country and
its people
will once again live in isolation for
cbs this morning saturday
roxanna saberi london